- But you were on stage actually,
and this is more of a serious thing,
but actually I had friends
at the Vegas shooting.
They were Brian, and actually
Brandon's best friend,
my husband's best friend.
He and his wife were there,
at the Vegas shooting when
it happened when you were
doing your show and everything.
And I just, I know you just
did a show in Vegas recently,
like, to kind of I don't know, I guess
what was the point of you doing that?
Because I, right when that happened,
our friends were literally
texting us during the shooting.
And we were like 'what?'
And it terrified me, to ever go on stage.
And I've been on stage forever.
- Yeah.
- But it just scares you,
because you're so vulnerable.
- Yeah, I mean it's, you know,
obviously something that I
wouldn't wish on anybody.
And you know, I think for us,
going back to Vegas was something that
I think we wanted to do it the right way.
We didn't want to go in
trying to do it too soon.
And we felt like there was going to be
a lot of people at our show that probably
haven't been to one of our
shows, maybe you haven't
been to a concert at all since that show.
And if they were going to come back out,
you know that was part of
the healing process for them.
You know, we wanted to make
it a safer environment.
Something that made them feel safer.
- Yeah.
- So we did Park MGM,
and so a little five thousand seat arena,
that you know, the other one was outside,
thirty, forty thousand
people, whatever it was.
- Yeah.
- And so this was a little smaller,
little more intimate
where people could come,
hopefully feel a little more at ease.
- Yeah.
- Hopefully it helps some of them.
I mean, we had to kind of
get on stage the next week,
you know.
And start trying to get
through all that, so.
- How did you do that, right off the bat?
Did you talk to anyone?
Because I'm telling you what-
- You know the best thing that-
- Especially having kids.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
Like it's not just you going
out there, you have a family.
- Ya, it's, I mean, it was rough.
I think the best thing
that could have happened,
was the fact,
not that could have happened,
but the best thing for me,
was the fact that my wife
was there, went through it,
my band was there, went
through it, my crew, everybody.
And so we kind of leaned on each other.
You know, for that stuff.
Kind of talked through it,
nobody kept it bottled up,
and if you had a breakdown,
you kind of had it in front of everybody
and everybody knew what was going on.
- Yeah.
- You know, my wife, we
could talk and she understood
what was going on, because she was there.
- Yeah.
- You know, and so it was, I think to me,
that probably helped more than anything.
But you know, were on the
other side of it now and
we're part of a group, not
only one family anymore.
- Yeah.
- So it's a cool group.
- It is, it is. It's a good thing.
(applause)